look gorgeous thank you when you and
Charlize I'm like girl crushing majorly
ha ha so you're being honored tonight
and we've heard nothing but amazing
things about your performance where did
you get the inspiration to play this
like boss lady lawyer well really from
Noah Baumbach script which is just
flawless and we both researched the
business of divorce in Los Angeles and
New York and its differences and you
know definitely was inspired by several
divorce attorneys who spend time and
really talked to us and told us about
the the heartbreak and the challenges of
the business and how often the family is
forgotten in the narrative of money
making between her and Renata like I
love all these powerful women you're
playing he's like babbles well I feel so
lucky because each character is powerful
but in such an incredibly different way
Renata this character and then in Little
Women which will be coming out soon I
find her so powerful but in a very warm
and generous and empathic way so very
lucky working with some incredible cast
- is there anybody still on your bucket
list right now like who you want to work
with oh my god everybody everybody I
mean my friends who I love working with
you know you find your tribe and you
just want to keep working together again
and again and again but you and Charlize
work together
but that would be amazing love it by the
way speaking of your girls morning shows
out have you watched any of it yet do
you know I promised Reese that I would
watch with my daughter so when I leave
here tonight
where we're going to binge watch
probably the entire thing I cannot wait
last question you're back for Jurassic
what can we expect for know I'm waiting
to hear what do you want to happen I
mean she's just gonna be heroic that's
all I know but I know nothing else thank
you
[Music]